Một người một thông mì một chuyến phủ anh đã cùng bụ gọi khai tổ được một tàn là phục đại tu lợn nhất trong một hình dập cư hấp sức
năm 2019, với hàng loạt thải đổi sấu dọng được với các quy định về định cư và nhiều cư hiện hàng.
Mà kể hoạt như gió thử dạm chờ sẽ chuyển định cư sẽ được kéo dài đang kể, lúc vui nhóm làu độ thủ nhất thấp,
nhóm người này sẽ phát chờ tối thì ở 15 năm, mở đủ điều kiện sin định cư, chồng khi đón với gì cư phụ thuộc của khúp lợi nhà nước,
hệ chờ tới 20 năm, lâu hơn 40 lần sau khi quy định hệ này và giả nhất tại cho ông.
Những người cứu chú bất đợ pháp quốc của 1 thị thật có thể hệ chờ tới 30 năm.
Chỉnh xe mới cũng quy định những người đảm mò hiếp phút ra lý tộc sẽ được quyền xin đến cư sau 1 năm.
Những cái nhân lột thời thu lập ở Mức cao sẽ có thời gian chờ ngân hơn nữa.
Một cách để chỉ phủ anh ghi nhận mất nặng quá của họ.
Theo bộ nội của anh, kê thông mới sẽ được áp dụng với gần 2 chụng người dí cư đã đến nước này từ 20 năm,
để chỉ thủ chụng hảm y mốt và khương anh hưởng tới những người đã có quy chế định cư đang xích sống ô định tại anh.